So on Tuesday I talked about George Washington and some of the reasons why he
proved so invaluable during and after the revolution.
And among other things I talked about the ways in which he proved time and again
that he could be trusted with power.
Well today and on Tuesday we're going to be looking at Washington empower,
commanding the continental army as we sketch out the chain of events on the
battlefield that ultimately resulted in American military victory.
Now in a sense,
today's lecture and Tuesday's lecture,
it's sort of one big lecture that I've arbitrarily divided in half cause I can't
fit it all into one lecture.
Um,
so we're going to get part of the fighting today and part of the fighting on
Tuesday and the dividing line will basically be however much I finished talking
about today is today's lecture.
And I'll pick up after that on Tuesday.
Um,
as your,
you'll see,
and I'll come to that in a few minutes.
Um,
I basically divided the fighting of the revolution into four phases.
and I'll explain in just a little bit why four phases and what that means and
why they make sense,
and then I'll sort of proceed through them as we unfold what's happening during
the actual fighting of the war and during both of electrodes.
During today's lectures and during Tuesday's lecture,
I'm going to be looking at the unfolding events from two vantage points,
so I'm not just going to be looking at how Americans view what's happening.
I'm going to try to get at both the British logic and the American logic as to
why they're doing what they're doing,
why they're strategy,
why their actions actually make sense,
because to really understand what's happening and why,
what ultimately did happen,
did it happen?
You really do need to understand the logic of both sides in this conflict.
Now,
in a sense,
the underlying question of both of these two lectures is how did America,
when I,
that's the real question.
How in the world in America,
when even to people at the time,
this hardly seems like the most probable outcome of this conflict when it was
undertaken and what we're going to be seeing today and on Tuesday is that
America's victory in the end was the result of a combination of factors.
I'm going to talk about a number of them at the beginning of the lecture and
then head off into battles now that we have sort of gotten an understanding of
some of the major complications and factors really complicating things for the
British more than anything else,
but I'll start out here just by listing some of the things I'm going to be
talking about briefly here at the outset of the lecture.
So combination of factors that help decide the outcome of the war.
One of them is as we'll see in just a moment,
British logistical disadvantages,
British assumptions about the logic of warfare and as we'll see,
some of these assumptions did not really apply well to the situation in North
America.
George Washington's strategy and the ways in which it's sometimes differed from
more conventional old world methods of fighting.
The different definitions of victory for the British and the Americans.
It's like again,
we'll see in a few minutes.
It meant something very different.
The British had to accomplish one thing where victory,
the Americans had to accomplish something different than in the end,
but the British had to accomplish as much more difficult than what the Americans
had to accomplish.
And I'll explain that momentarily.
So British logistical disadvantages,
British assumptions about the logic of warfare,
George Washington strategy and the different definitions of victory for the
British and the Americans are some of the factors that help decide the outcome
of the war in favor of the Americans.
Now,
what I'm not going to go into here,
and I will go into it on Tuesday,
um,
which is another major factor that helped the Americans when the war.
That's the French,
that's actually the French joining the war on the side of the Americans.
That has a huge impact for a whole bunch of reasons.
As I'll talk about next week.
I'm not going to go into that into detail now,
but I will say that it's hard to imagine the Americans really winning the war
without the assistance of the French and we'll see that play out on Tuesday.
Now before we start talking about the unfolding of the war,
um,
I do want to look for just a few minutes on some of these challenges
particularly that faced the British at the opening of the fighting of the
revolution and how circumstances in the American revolution.
We're different than circumstances in some of the previous wars that the British
had fought.
And in a way,
this leads us to the first of that chain of things I just mentioned a minute
ago.
British logistical disadvantages.
In a sense,
that's what I'm going to be talking about right now.
The ways in which the war and the American colonies presented some logistical
complications that the British hadn't necessarily faced in this same way and
with the same combination of factors before.
For one thing,
in a way,
the most fundamental thing of all was just the simple question of supplies.
The most basic,
basic,
logistical concern of them all.
Because more commonly in the past when the British had fought wars in distant
territory's,
often they're colonists,
had provided supplies and even men to the British army,
we'll obviously now the colonists are the enemy.
So that's not going to be happening in this particular war.
So instead of a [inaudible] stream of local supplies and local forces,
British supplies and men had to be shipped over 3000 miles of ocean and then
lugged around the entire eastern seaboard trailing after the British army and
countryside that often was not really friendly to lugging around vast amounts of
supplies following an army.
And as we'll be seeing shortly,
two of the most significant battles of the war ended up being lost by the
British in part because of problems with the simple matter of supplies.
So that's one logistical problem.
A second logistical problem for the British involved,
the huge expanse of land that constituted the colonies.
Basically the battlefield of this war.
It's pretty extensive.
It's an enormous stretch of land stretching from what would one day be,
Florida,
um,
all the way up to Canada.
And for a little while into Canada and from the Atlantic coast to the
Mississippi.
Unlike more traditional wars,
more conventional wars wars have a thought that Britain would have been more
used to fighting.
There wasn't one central target to attack that could turn the tide of war.
And,
and the British don't necessarily know this and we're going to see them actually
try to play out the strategy more than once during the war.
But in fact,
there was not one central target that they could have grabbed and turned the
tide of war.
Usually a really good military strategy was to capture a nation's capitol or the
center of government.
And sometimes that really would help push a war to its conclusion.
You capture the Capitol symbolically and also as a source of power and
leadership.
And sometimes that really does push a war to its conclusion.
But in the American colonies,
and then after 1776 states,
there wasn't any one city that represented America,
center of government.
There was one no one single real American capital,
no one core of American strength.
And so as we'll see shortly throughout the war,
the British struggle to determine which major cities capture might defeat the
American cause and bring victory to Britain and obviously in the end,
this is not a strategy that worked in the Americans
states.
A third logistical problem had less to do with America and more to do with
Britain and that is that the British found it extremely difficult to raise
troops to fight this war.
First of all,
just fighting in a far away overseas war would not have been popular in and of
itself.
Add to this,
the fact that there were some potential soldiers who would not have been that
enthusiastic about attacking British colonists and you end up with a serious
problem in lifting men and raising a large enough forth for this war.
As a result of the British ended up hiring a large number of German mercenary
troops from a number of different independent German states and they ended up
getting lumped under the heading Hessian.
That's sort of how we know them as Hessians and this practice in and of itself
in raged Americans all the more because it suggested to them that the British
were hiring what they would have considered to be foreign assassins to kill
their own colonists.
Fourth and related to everything that I've just said,
and as I said at the outset,
the British and the Americans had different definitions of victory for the
British to win the war,
they had to stamp out a widespread rebellion unfolding under a vast expanse of
land.
They had to destroy the American cause to emerge victorious from this war.
The Americans did not have to defeat the British to win the war.
They just had to keep fighting long enough to exhaust British funding and
supplies and energy.
So for the Americans,
the ultimate goal was just to keep fighting,
to keep the war going,
to force the British to expend as much money and as much manpower and as much
energy as possible.
And as we'll see in today's lecture,
Washington took full advantage of this fact and fought the war with a strategy
that maybe wasn't always really inspiring for onlookers,
but was highly effective in exhausting the British forces.
And then finally fifth,
a fifth logistical problem for the British actually wasn't so much about the
American colonies or the British as it was about the British longtime enemy,
the French,
the British could not just turn their back on the rest of the world to entirely
dedicate all of their time and efforts to this colonial revolt.
They had to keep their eye on their longtime enemy,
the French,
particularly after 1778 when the French joined the war on the side of the
American colonists.
As I said,
I'll talk about that and more detailed Tuesday,
but once the French are in the war,
suddenly now the British and in particular the British navy after really be
worrying about what the French are doing,
like what?
What are they doing down there in the West indies,
those French?
Do we need to send ships to the West indies and defend some of our properties
there?
That really further complicates things for the British,
so they can't just focus on what's going on in these North American colonies.
Okay.
So they are always seen a couple of different logistical complications for the
British supplies,
problems with supplies.
The problem with figuring out where is the best place to stage and attack the
problem of raising troops.
The fact that victory meant something different for the British than it did for
the Americans.
And then the complications introduced by the French.
In addition to all of these logistical problems,
there was the simple problem,
or at least certainly the unique challenges that faced the British and staging a
war fought by a citizen army.
The British army was an impressive force,
but it more typically fought conventional European wars tended to be fought on
open plains and open country where lines of troops advanced on each other until
one line or the other weekend from casualties and retreated.
And that's like a warm,
which you have men who are disciplined and trained to stay in rank and file as
this battle rages until finally the tide turns in one side or the other wins or
loses.
This is not the way that the American war unfolded.
Although it is worth saying,
I think a lot of Americans have this image in their head that the Americans were
these sort of guerrilla combat full,
he knows sort of around hiding behind trees and the sort of befuddled British
are marching and they're bright red coats getting shot down in massive numbers.
And the fact of the matter is the British were not oblivious to the situation,
the military situation,
and they didn't sort of March single file and getting mowed down by people
hiding behind trees.
The factories that the British did,
among other things make pretty skillful use of native Americans in staging their
own version of guerrilla warfare.
So they're not sort of just hanging on to old world methods of fighting and
ignoring what's going on here in the new world.
But even so,
there were a lot of challenges that they faced and fighting against a citizen
army.
For one thing,
a citizen army is just not going to be as predictable as a professionally
trained force.
Sometimes the continental army abided by predictable military conventions,
sometimes they didn't.
And we'll hear a little bit of this today.
I've talked about it a little bit before.
The continental army people who were always leaving the continental army when
their term was up in new people came.
And so in a sense,
you kept having untrained people joining the continental army again and again
and again.
So it's not even as though necessarily after a while these men were sort of all
longterm soldiers and knew what they were doing.
That was never entirely true.
So a citizen army is unpredictable also.
It's not just an army that the British are facing.
Americans,
generally speaking,
we're prepared to fight if necessary,
not just soldiers,
but farmers.
If the British attacked a locality,
the people there were prepared to defend themselves and their land and their
property.
We've already seen that just in the talk that I gave about new haven,
where you'd have professor Daggett sort of writing out and that the eal students
writing out to sort of fend off the British.
So in addition to whatever actual organized army you have,
you've just got local citizens who are getting involved in whatever's happening
as events and battles come into their own backyard.
So the British face,
not only an army but armed citizens as well.
A third challenging aspect of a citizen army was yet again something that wasn't
necessarily a common aspect of wars fought by the British army in the past and
that is Americans are not just fighting for defense of a realm or defense of a
monarch intellectually they were fighting for political liberties and ultimately
for independence,
which would have felt like a more inspiring because too many people a personal
cause.
It would have been something that people had a personal connection with and
certainly gave Americans some staying power and endurance during the war.
So that the cause again persisted.
We'll see even today one or two low points,
at which point you would think things might have just faded and they don't.
And part of it has to do with the personal implications in the personal meaning
of the war to the people who were fighting it in the American states.
Plus personally,
many Americans were fighting for their own property and their own land.
Right.
Even more personal,
as I just mentioned a moment ago,
if the,
if there's an army advancing on your town,
that's about as personal award as it can be and again,
it's going to bring people out in numbers and with a kind of determination and
enthusiasm that they might not have in a different kind of a war.
So having a citizen army,
the kind of citizen army,
the kind of warfare is going to be taking place in the colonies.
Also all by itself presented some pretty interesting challenges to the British
army.
Okay.
So we've seen a host of logistical challenges,
some complications I'm going to throw into this mix.
Three bad assumptions on the part of the British that did not help their cause.
Okay.
Bad assumption number one,
they continue to underestimate the Americans.
They continue to underestimate the persistence of the Americans,
the abilities of the Americans,
the impact of whatever the Americans were doing and right alongside with that,
they overestimated their popularity among American loyalists and the power that
they had among American loyalists.
Now,
probably part of that overestimating loyalist support was born from reports of
overly optimistic royal officials and governors who reported back to London that
yes,
there's plenty of loyalists here and there on hand to defend the cause.
And when things get underway,
the loyalist will rise up and be on our side.
And there were some loyalists there,
a good number of loyalists who actually did join and fight with the British.
Again,
when I was talking about the invasion of new haven,
we saw just here in the town of new haven,
how some people chose to help the British,
others,
their neighbors chose to fight against them.
So there were a loyalist who chose at any given moment to join and support
British troops as opposed to the continental army or American troops.
But even so,
discussion of really widespread loyalist support was exaggerated.
And because of these sort of rosier than they should've been reports,
British officials in England,
far from the American scene,
assumed that many colonies were basically loyalist.
And all in all,
you just needed a little bit of a shove and things would be brought right.
They assume that probably there's a small band of radicals that are making
trouble.
You hear this again and again and again.
When you read British commentary on what's happening,
there's a band of radicals who are poisoning the public mind,
but that there are also loyalists who will rise up and help the British cost.
So it won't take very much for this to be pushed into some kind of a conclusion
that certainly towards the beginning of the war,
something that the British assume the British army didn't help matters as far as
the loyalists are concerned with their behavior.
In some of the colonies,
particularly in the south,
the British army looted farms,
trampled fields paraded their superiority and so there are places in the south
where the British army was a little patriot creating machine where you had
people who might've been loyalists leaning,
but they did not like the way that they were treated by the British army and so
pulled back from supporting the British when they might have started out leaning
in that direction.
Okay,
so we have underestimating Americans,
overestimating support of the loyalists.
The third bad assumption at the outset of the war is that the British navy would
accomplish most of the damage and largely when the war,
because Britain did have this colossal impressive navy,
it was really what Britain was famous for militarily was its navy,
but England hadn't thought a long sustained land campaign for quite some time.
And when it had fought long land campaigns in the past,
often they haven't fought with allies who supplied land power to complement
Britain's naval forces.
So as we're about to see all of these bad assumptions joined with all of those
logistical things that I mentioned at the outset of the elector,
all of these together are not helping the British as the war unfolds and they
all play a role in the outcome of the war.
Okay,
let's now turn to the actual war to the actual battles.
Um,
as I suggested at the outcome,
the opening of the lecture,
I divided the war into four phases.
As we'll see,
each of these phases is initiated by a sort of major decision of,
of strategy or policy on the part of the British.
Um,
often it's a strategy that's initiated by an assumption that makes perfect sense
to the British,
but that does not end up being,
this is really a good strategy given the situation at the time and again and
again is these phases unfold.
You'll see the British make what to them seems like a logical decision and then
you'll see it not play out particularly well.
It's certainly not in the way that the British really wanted this to play out.
So let's turn to the first phase of the war.
And we've already seen a little bit of this first phase earlier on when I talked
about Lexington and Concord and Bunker Hill,
this early phase of the war was guided by the main assumption on the part of the
British that all the Americans needed was a little display of force,
a little bit of military coercion and the war would come to a quick close.
So basically just sort of impress upon them the stupidity of what they are doing
right.
Rear the British army,
we will come in and remind them what they are doing.
They will be reminded that they're behaving illogically and one way or another,
this will end maybe a little reconciliation,
a little friendly sort of gesture on our part towards the colonists.
And we can bring this whole thing to a close.
And Lexington and Concord are part of that strategy,
right?
Just a little display,
a force,
and everything's going to be settled.
Of course the outcome is not what they would expect.
It's just the opposite.
And the British movements,
the British troop movements call forth an outpouring of American enthusiasm and
enlistments and alarm,
which was further bolstered by America's victories or I guess you could call
them sort of semi victories.
I don't know what to call Bunker Hill.
It's sort of a victory,
but it's sort of isn't.
But certainly some Americans at the time,
I suppose because they weren't crushed to death,
would have seen bunker hill as a victory.
Um,
but so the fact that things were sort of persisting and they were standing up to
the British at bunker hill in June of 1775 and at Fort Ticonderoga in May of
1775,
that sort of helps to bolster American spirits.
Now I have discussed a little bit the battle of Bunker Hill and you might
remember that that's the battle in which the British held the ground at the end
of the day.
But at the cost of so many men,
almost half of the men that were fighting there that day that their victory,
it didn't really seem to be much of a victory at all,
which is why you can sort of call it a semi victory on both sides.
Um,
and I mentioned in Tuesday's lecture that New York Times article that I had
stumbled across that morning about that bundle of letters that were going to be
sold at Southerby's,
them that it can t had all of these letters between,
um,
British generals and diplomats who were in America writing to each other,
not back to London,
but to each other about what they were really thinking about.
What was unfolding,
and there's a letter from General John.
We're going British General John for going after the battle of Bunker Hill.
He's one of the leading generals in the colonies at that point,
and he says in this letter to someone else in America that after that battle he
believes that British military prospects in America seem to use his word gloomy,
such a pittance of troops as Great Britain and Ireland can supply,
will only serve to protract the war,
to incur fruitless expense and ensure disappointment.
Our victory has been bought by an uncommon loss of officers.
Some of them are reparable and I fear the consequence will not answer the
expectations that will be raised in England,
I guess.
So there's,
we're going saying,
okay,
you know,
we won the battle of Bunker Hill.
This just doesn't look good to me.
He even says in that same letter or something along the lines of,
when I think back into my history books and my sort of military history past,
I can't seem to come up with a situation that quite looks like this one.
This is just weird.
I don't know what to have in a year,
but it doesn't look good to me.
It looks gloomy and I,
victory was actually pretty distressing and it's not going to look particularly
wonderful to people in England when they see,
it's certainly not what they're gonna be expecting from us at the outset of
fighting here in the colonies.
So there's bunker hill.
I've mentioned that before.
I don't know if I mentioned Fort Ticonderoga before.
I'll reiterate it here if I have,
and if not,
you'll get it for the first time.
Um,
it was an important battle for the American war effort as well as just for
American morale.
Um,
Fort Ticonderoga is a strategic fort in upstate New York that was held by the
British and in May of 1775 American troops led by Ethan Allen and Benedict
Arnold.
We're going to have a lot of benedict Arnold today.
You can see why he's like this big hero.
And that's why it was so shocking that he did what he did ultimately and
deserted.
He's a hero through all of today's lecture here.
He's starting out.
His heroic acts at the battle of Fort Ticonderoga,
Ethan Allen and Benedict Arnold are leading.
They actually surprise the British garrison and they won control of the fort
declaring their victory as Ethan Allen put it very dramatically.
And the name of the Great Jehovah and the Continental Congress.
I take Fort Ticonderoga,
it's guys,
no drama.
TheU s suffered one wounded soldier.
The British had 48 men captured plus cannons,
mortars,
Musket,
Flint ammunition,
and these kinds of supplies were really invaluable for the American cause
generally,
and specifically at this moment they were really useful because the Americans
take the supplies,
particularly these cannons that they win at Fort Ticonderoga and they loved them
to Boston and they positioned them looking down on the city of Boston and not
that long after the British evacuated Boston.
Right.
Which is what they would've wanted.
So Marcia 1776 the British say,
okay,
we lost I kind of Yoga and there's canyon looking down on us.
I think it's time to leave Boston now.
As long as I'm in upstate New York,
I'm going to mention some bad assumptions on the part of Americans as well.
At this point,
there was always the feeling in America and particularly during the very
beginning of the war that Canada was just waiting to be liberated from England,
right?
That Quebec is just waiting to be the 48th state,
so after winning Ticonderoga,
part of the American army actually went north to attack Quebec and free it,
right?
This idea like free Canada,
Canada doesn't want to be freed.
It's just these Americans that are like,
yeah,
they're just waiting for us to come.
So they staged this attack on Quebec to free it.
It's this,
as you'll see today on Tuesday,
this is pretty much a defensive war on the part of the Americans.
This is the one little moment or one of very few little moments that's really
just an offensive invasion on the part of the Americans once again and addict
darnel there he is being heroic during the attack.
So as the young Aaron Burr who fought in this battle and supposedly pulled the
body of his General Richard Montgomery off of the battlefield under heavy fire.
And since I think Montgomery was a big person and Aaron Burr was a very small
person,
I think this is a hard thing to do.
And he became sort of a hero afterwards for being the guy who saved his generals
body under heavy fire during battle.
Ultimately,
the Americans did not liberate Canada.
The Canadians just were not interested in joining the American war effort.
Not even when a delegation from the continental Congress arrived in Canada,
led by Benjamin Franklin to negotiate with the Canadians about joining the
revolts.
So the Americans are serious about this.
The effort to free Canada ended without effect.
And ultimately during this war,
at least the Americans abandoned the idea about liberating Canada.
And I say during this war at least because during the war of 1812 and once
again,
we're fighting the British.
The Americans are right back there.
It's like,
no.
Number two,
you know,
go away.
But they're back.
They're persistent.
Now,
the main part of the American army at this point in 1776 after the evacuation of
Boston by the British is not in Canada.
After the British evacuated Boston,
Washington and the main body of American troops went to New York City,
convinced that after evacuating Boston,
that's likely to be where the British head to New York City.
And sure enough,
that's exactly what the British do.
Thomas Gauge commander of the British forces had been recalled by this time and
he'd been replaced by Sir William Howe who arrives in New York City in July of
1776 okay,
so here we see another British assumption that does not play out the way in
which clearly the British hope it would.
I said a few minutes ago they assumed a little show of force,
a little show of reconciliation and this will end and we've seen a little show
of force here.
We see an attempt at reconciliation.
The idea of being maybe if we sort of extend a hand in some way,
this will end.
So newly installed general,
how invited and American Commission to hold a peace conference with him.
On a boat in New York harbor.
This ends up being known as the Staten Island Peace Conference and somehow it's
just have no issue with Staten Island,
but I just don't expect that all those words to go together.
You stop in island piece governance,
um,
which is held September 11th,
at the conference.
How tells the American Commissioners Benjamin Franklin,
John Adams making a little appearance and south Carolinian,
Edward Rutledge,
all of them,
they're from the continental congress that he would hate to be forced to destroy
his brothers.
The Americans.
He's wishing that he there was something they could do so that he can be spared
the horror of having to kill his brethren at which point France and supposedly
responded by saying,
we will try our best to spare you the trouble.
Thank you Benjamin Franklin.
Okay.
That conference did not accomplish what the British wanted it to accomplish.
Nothing happens as a result of the Staten Island peace conference.
How also wrote to George Washington to see if he could get Washington to come to
terms with the British.
Right.
Maybe.
Maybe if I just deal with him personally.
He'll see that I'm being reasonable and work towards ending this before it
really begins.
Unfortunately.
This is the letter that I mentioned yes on a Tuesday addressed to Mr. Washington
that he did not want to accept because it wasn't addressed to General
Washington,
the etc,
etc. Letter.
So basically how refuses to address Washington with his military title and
Washington refuses to accept the letter.
So this does not go well either.
That's just like oops.
Oh well that's an attempt to just stall it before it even gets underway.
So there we have basically the first phase of the war.
This idea that a little push,
a little shove,
a little display of force,
a little reconciliation and things will end.
The second phase begins with a switch in strategy on the part of the British,
a new strategy.
But again,
one that's still grounded in traditional assumptions about warfare.
And this new strategy is accompanied by another assumption that does not play
out well.
Little shove strategy doesn't work.
So now basically we'll up the stakes is what the British were thinking.
We'll see as a major city.
Basically the British assumed that if they seized New York,
they would split the colonies in half along the Hudson Valley and end the war to
them.
It seemed pretty simple and easy to divide the colonies into two halves.
And particularly since at this point they still think that the center of all the
trouble is New England,
that there were these sort of crazy radical people in New England.
So if they can see as New York and divide the colonies in half an isolate New
England,
then maybe things will actually end quickly.
So that's the strategy here as we move into phase number two of the fighting.
So the British descended on New York with an armada bearing 32,000 troops.
Okay,
that's just awe inspiring numbers of men,
Washington dug in on Brooklyn Heights,
hoping that the British would attack him frontally and that there'd be another
kind of bunker hill sort of battle.
But instead,
how carried out some kind of a flanking maneuver,
which resulted in American losses of nearly 1500 men compared with British
losses of less than 400 men.
However,
at this point,
how made a mistake of a sort that he made repeatedly again and again throughout
the war.
He's so competent victory that he decides he won't deliver the final death blow
until the next day.
Right?
Oh,
what the night pass tomorrow morning we'll get up and crush them.
Okay.
Washington is the expert of retreat overnight.
Washington removes his troops under cover of darkness from Brooklyn Heights and
brings them into New York and we'll see.
I think even in the course of today's lecture,
how does this,
again,
that he does well in a battle,
he assumes that things are going so swimmingly that okay,
tomorrow we'll finish things off and Washington manages to make a hasty retreat
and things continue.
So Washington removes his troops under cover of darkness to New York City and
basically for the next two months there,
there's a series of minor battles in New York.
There's one in Harlem Heights,
there's one in white plains.
How keeps trying to circle the continental army and Washington keeps retreating
one way or another pretty skillfully helped always and his retreating by the
fact that how it's so slow to just advance and conquer.
Ultimately,
Washington fled across New Jersey over the Delaware River while Howe,
who now is in possession of New York,
also sees is Newport,
Rhode Island and establishes outposts in New Jersey.
So things are not looking wonderful for the Americans at this point and the
British seem to be doing quite well.
But here we do see one of Washington's most characteristic warm maneuvers
because rather than just sort of standing there and engaging with the British,
he withdraws and he withdraws and he withdraws again and again and again
throughout the entire war.
He continually maneuvered his army so that at the circumstances didn't seem
overwhelmingly favorable for the American army.
He could just retreat to a more secure spot.
Now obviously the strategy of retreat would not have been necessarily
overwhelmingly inspiring to Americans at the time.
It did not also necessarily strike fear into the hearts of the British.
At first,
Washington's The guy who retreats this sump had some people feeling a little bit
gloomy and not always hopeful.
He's the army that disappears.
But now in 1776 Washington uses this typical strategy.
He doesn't want to get pinned into New York City.
He retreats across New Jersey retreats across the Delaware,
goes into Pennsylvania.
The British had after him as far as Trenton,
New Jersey,
led by British General Lord Cornwallis and there they go into winter quarters.
And Lord Cornwallis had arrived in America in 1776 and he brought with him even
more British troops.
And here we have yet another letter from that collection I mentioned being sold
at Southerby's.
And this one's from an observer who's on a ship,
a British ship in New York harbor.
As he's watching the Americans leave New York and he's riding again to somebody
else.
He's a diplomat.
He's writing to someone else in the colonies and he says that he's,
he watched the colonists abandoned their homes,
quote to follow the standard of rebellion at the hazard of all their worth
rather than acknowledged George for their king.
The infatuation is inscrutable.
I have read somewhere and I began to think it possible that a whole country as
well as an individual maybe struck with lunacy.
He can't believe what he's seeing,
right?
He's watching Washington's army run and he watches some colonists,
basically follow,
abandoned what they own and follow as he puts it.
Rather than acknowledged George for their king,
he can't quite believe what he's seeing now by this point.
This is December of 1776 Washington had roughly 3000 men fit for duty in the
army.
It was a sad point for Washington to the army.
It's at this point that Thomas Paine makes another appearance,
comes to the fore again.
He writes a series of pamphlets published under the title of the crisis,
and the first one appears in December of 1776 actually,
I think December 19th,
1776 by this point,
pain had actually joined the American army.
So he's in the army and he wrote these crisis essays while he was in the army
and Washington had them read to the troops to boost their morale.
And as with common sense,
these crisis essays include some of the most famous pros of the revolutionary
era.
And I'll just read the most obvious lines,
which some of you probably already know.
These are the times that try men's souls.
The summer soldier and the sunshine Patriot will in this crisis,
shrink from the service of their country,
but he that stands by it now deserves the love and thanks of man and woman
tyranny like hell is not easily conquered.
Yet we have this consolation with us that the harder the conflict,
the more glorious the triumph.
He's good at coming forward at tough moments.
And then having these sort of inspiring words again,
which is why Washington's having them read to the troops.
Paine's words were really needed in December of 1776 because it's a real low
point for Washington and the army failure literally seem to be just on the
horizon.
In less than three months,
the British had captured New York City,
they had captured part of New Jersey food supplies and pay in the American army
were at an all time low and almost worst of all enlistments of soldiers in the
continental army ended at the end of the year.
It's a Washington.
There he is and he knows that the people in the continental army,
their formal enlistments and at the end of December,
and they could all just walk away and say,
well I,
my enlistments done.
Thanks sir.
Nice fighting with you.
Goodbye.
And Washington could literally be left without an army.
So he ha he does one last desperate measure literally to prevent the army from
entirely disappearing.
He uses the only thing that's available to him at this moment and that is his
personal influence.
He makes a personal plea to the army to please stay with him for just six more
weeks.
As a personal favor to him.
I please don't leave just for me,
for your commander.
Just give me six more weeks and then you can go as a personal favor to me.
Who you respect.
Give me just six more weeks.
Most of the soldiers agreed.
And with that Washington made one last desperate attempt to attack the British
at Trenton,
New Jersey and Washington strategy is good in this case.
He basically waits until Christmas,
really banking on the element of surprise.
And then he launches a surprise attack against an encampment of Hessians at
Trenton and he wins the day with a loss of only for men and he gains roughly 900
prisoners.
This is the,
this is great for Washington and says such such a low moment and he really does
get the element of surprise.
The Hessians are just sort of stunned and at first apparently think that there's
like a little sort of advanced guard of Americans who are attacking them and
they suddenly realized their horror.
Like,
no,
this would be the American army.
We're in trouble and they fight and there was a battle,
but again,
they really lose the day.
The British learning of the attack are somewhat distressed.
However,
they think they assume at this point that they have the American army cornered
at Trenton and thus may decide the next day they will attack the continental
army.
Okay.
So once again,
they're not good at the element of surprise.
The British,
they keep sort of taking their time,
taking your time with not good at this point of the word.
It's not a strategy that is working for the British.
So sure enough,
Washington does what Washington does so well.
He retreats under cover of night and in this case,
rather than just retreating,
he actually leaves campfires burning in their camp.
So it looks as though the army is still there and then leaving what looks like
the encampment there under complete darkness.
He moves his troops away directly into enemy lines in Princeton,
New Jersey,
which she also captured again,
he did two unexpected things.
He manages to retreat.
He pretends as though he's not retreating.
And then he moves his troops into enemy lines and Princeton and captures it.
Now during the battle,
supposedly there was a cannon ball that was shot through Nassau Hall,
you know,
the big main hall of Prince and the College of New Jersey.
And there's a story that goes along with that.
There's no actual evidence to support the story,
but I'll offer it cause people tell it over and over and over again.
So clearly someone somewhere believes it and even though it might not be true,
I'll give it to you anyway.
Um,
the,
the story is basically that Alexander Hamilton is the guy who shot the cannon or
had the Canon shot that went through Nassau Hall at the College of New Jersey.
The theory behind that being,
he actually really wanted to go to the College of New Jersey.
He's fighting,
he is fighting at the battle of Princeton and he wants to go.
That's his first choice college.
Like,
where do I want to go?
Oh,
the College of New Jersey.
But he's in such a hurry.
He wants to advance through the program at Princeton as fast as he can.
So basically I don't want to have to wait for everyone else,
like if I finish a course and a month,
then I want to move onto the next one.
This is a little bit of a radical proposal and the people with Princeton at the
College of New Jersey say,
um,
no.
So he ends up going to King's College to Columbia instead,
he is fighting at the battle of Princeton.
He is in command.
It was small artillery group,
which is firing cannon.
So the story is,
you know,
he was rather pleased to see a cannon ball go firing into Nassau Hall since they
had rejected him.
Basically they didn't take him for college one way or another.
Washington wins at Trenton,
Washington wins at Princeton and then he settles into winter quarters at
Morristown New Jersey for the winter of 1776.
So basically in nine days in the dead of winter and really in the dead of winter
when gentlemen do not normally stage military campaigns in a traditional war,
the American army pushed the British back 60 miles from their ultimate goal,
which was Philadelphia.
And as important,
the battles of Trenton and Princeton were vital to American morale,
to civilian morale and military morale alike.
As an Englishman said at the time a few days ago,
he's American's had given up the costs for lust.
They're late,
successes have turned to the scale,
and now they're all liberty.
Matt again,
they have recovered from their panic and it will not be an easy matter to throw
them into that confusion again.
So here ends the second phase of the war with the eastern seaboard.
Definitely not cut in half.
The Americans definitely not defeated.
The third phase of the war begins in 1777 largely,
it consisted of the British attempting to subdue the middle colonies.
Once again,
proceeding under the assumption that if they get the right city,
it will cause things to end.
In this case,
they think,
okay,
we,
we did New York,
we're heading for Philadelphia,
yet another major city and the governments in Philadelphia.
So maybe if we managed to get that city as well,
things will turn our way.
That's how things happen in a conventional war.
Capture a key city,
things turn your way often and again in America,
this is not a strategy that works well at Cornwallis put it at the time.
In the end he decides that the only way to really defeat the Americans would be
to catch George Washington or as Cornwallis bullet put it to bag the Fox.
Right.
That's though he sounded like a traditional Fox side.
We have to bad but thoughts and then it will be over.
I Dunno if Philadelphia is going to do it,
but at any rate,
the British do head off for Philadelphia,
1777 the third phase of the war.
This is how his plan and at first the British do well in Pennsylvania there are
actually a couple of clashes in Pennsylvania at Brandywine and at Germantown and
both times continental army units crumbled and how it was ultimately able to
enter Philadelphia and in these skirmishes one after another,
nearly 20% of the continental troops were either killed,
wounded,
or captured.
So the British are doing pretty well at first,
I'm not helping matters as far as American morale goes is the fact that when
Congress hears that the British are headed for Philadelphia,
they run in mass panic like
British are coming,
which does not really make the continental army feel like they have much faith
in them to protect them.
Right.
They literally like lead down.
There's actually a really amusing letter,
I think by this point.
Alexander Hamilton is an aid to George Washington.
He sends a letter to the continental congress basically saying,
so the sell Condo,
he flees to another city in Pennsylvania.
So things are looking good for the British in Pennsylvania.
However,
further north,
something else is happening to the wing of the British army that had been in
Canada and now is headed south,
led by British General John.
We're going in a battle at Saratoga,
New York with Burger joints,
troops suffering from some supply problems.
So here we have a battle where supplies are major problem.
We're going ends up at the battle of Saratoga surrendering almost 6,000 men to
American forces led by general ratio gates and aided by Benedict Arnold,
the man who appears to be everywhere in this phase of the war for the Americans.
This feels like a real turning point.
I mean,
it's a stunning victory for the Americans,
really unexpected and it's just a stunning,
a defeat for the British.
And there's actually a journal entry by one of Brian's lieutenants describing
the events with the British commander,
with Burgoyne and with the troops and the surrender.
He describes what he sees and he writes in his journal General,
we're going desired a meeting of all the officer's early that morning at which
he entered into a detail of his manner of acting since he had the honor of
commanding the army.
So basically we're going to cause all of his officers and he's trying to explain
to them how they ended up in the situation that they're in,
how,
what logic did he follow so that they're where they are now.
And the lieutenant continues in his diary that per going with quote too full to
speak,
heaven only could tell his feelings at this time about 10 o'clock we marched out
according to treaty,
marched out to surrender with drums beating,
but the drum seemed to have lost their former inspiriting sounds and seemed as
if almost ashamed to be heard on such an occasion as to my own feelings.
I can not express them tears though unmanly forced their way and if alone,
I could have burst to give myself vent.
I never shall forget the appearance of the American troops are marching past
them.
A dead silence universally range through their numerous columns and even they
seem struck with our situation and Derris they're scarce.
Lift up their eyes to view British troops in such a situation,
I must say they're decent behavior during the time to us,
so greatly fallen,
merited,
the utmost approbation and praise.
So he's actually describing this shocking moment where the British can't believe
they're surrendering that number of men to the American forces.
And the Americans are so stunned that this is happening,
that they're actually just silently watching it.
They can't,
no one can quite believe what's happening at Saratoga.
It's a huge victory.
It has important consequences that I'll talk about more next Tuesday as we head
into the last phase of the war,
which largely takes place in the south and see its repercussions and its
implications.
Um,
have a great weekend.
I think lurking somewhere is that sheet of paper.
I assume it made its way somewhere.
Whoever has that magical sheet of paper up there.
It is.
Okay to bring it up when you're done.
Have a great weekend.